foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to Rotten Tomatoes is
Ron my name is Mark Ellis or you may
know me this time of year as the plus
one to miss Jacqueline Coley not only
the co-host here today but also she's in
the midst of award season she's hobnob
and you invited me to an event I could
have been your plus one I you were at
the London I was which is right down the
street from The Comedy Store this has
been a Thing If a sunset Tower the
London are the two locations that are
closest to The Comedy Store I'm usually
known to be found he's there on occasion
I haunt it and so whenever I know I'm
doing an event around the time that he
would be on stage which for folks that
don't know is usually we're out or
around the time you'd be near there
eight to ten is my like sweet spot as
long as I'm gonna be in there I can I
can find him but he wasn't he wasn't he
was having better fun with the
four-legged friend with Molly the Wonder
Dog and uh yeah well I guess somebody
who's a very special guest today who has
had some fun some fun with four-legged
and two-legged creatures according to
the Jurassic world franchise would be
Daniela Pineda who is also the star of
the new movie plane with Gerard Butler
number one new movie at the box office
the weekend it came out and it's fresh
on the Tomato Meter congratulations yeah
thank you thank you I'm I'm uh I'm
pleased I will say this also we got a
shout out by your co-star uh Mr Gerard
Butler I think he's a man that really
loves every movie of his that comes out
fresh because he was literally like you
have no idea how happy this makes me
yeah yeah it exceeded I mean we knew uh
it just exceeded everybody's
expectations and then after I finally
got to see it I was like yeah this is a
really good it's a really good action
movie from what yeah it's legit yeah
it's totally legit it's um I think uh I
also really like the review that um well
obviously I love the Rotten Tomatoes
review firstly but uh uh Washington Post
said it's um it's uh cinematic junk food
but tastes so good and I was like thank
you for acknowledging for it for what it
is I mean look we all are gonna be
suckers and eventually want McDonald's
fries like you smell it and that's what
I imagine is gonna be and I apologize to
you I haven't seen plan as of this
report I'm sorry I was gonna go see it I
had I had stuff come up but he's gonna
see it I'm gonna see I love we were
talking about uh Olympus Has Fallen on
this show a few weeks ago four planes so
we've already commemorated this movie in
our small way yeah later that day I I
was watching TV I was watching football
or something and I saw Daniella in an ad
for playing and I was like oh she's in
plan oh we should talk now and now we're
here and I said Daniella what movie do
you want to talk about do you want to
defend that the tomato got wrong it's
kind of the name of the show and you
picked the cell yeah from the year 2000
starring Jennifer Lopez Vince Vaughn
directed by tarsome Singh 45
rotten on the Tomato Meter the audience
score rebounds a little bit 57 and one
of the reasons we're talking about is
because Miss Pineda is a big fan I think
yeah and Jennifer Lopez is in shotgun
wedding with Josh dumel and that drops
on Amazon think it's out now so as of
this recording it is out now let's get
to you first you pick the cell you're
like this is the movie I want to talk
about and defend so I'm guessing if I
ask you yeah is Rotten Tomatoes wrong
about the cell I do think Rotten
Tomatoes it might be might be wrong I
mean uh you know obviously the the
audience will will speak for themselves
um but I feel like sometimes we forget
at the time which something came out it
was really Innovative I don't think you
should compare it to what's out now you
have to think of two thousand and for me
going to theaters being what was I like
I think was eighth grade ninth grade Y2K
oh oh hell yeah I remember that I was
Brave for the world to shut down but
going to the theaters and seeing first
of all this checked a lot of boxes for
me it was a lead uh Latina I'm gonna be
really really hot we're like yeah and
then she you know and then it's horror
which is my favorite genre and Thriller
and sci-fi and procedural and procedural
yeah so what are you talking about yeah
47 that's wrong okay so uh Jacqueline do
you agree that the Tomato Meter got it
wrong here again we're 45 of the Tomato
Meter 57 audience score where do you
land I think the audience score is a
little bit more correct um I would
definitely say that I could get this one
to Fresh which is surprising to me when
I went to re-watch it that I was
automatically putting it at Fresh
because as you know I have my
Constantine litmus test and I love
Constantine I really do and I think that
score is Criminal but I would put this
up where I would put where I think
Constantine should be right yeah I would
put that up there and I'm like I always
said Constantine is a great like you
know I think plain is what 71 like 68
somewhere in there like probably 74 yeah
you know what I mean so it's like kind
of that sort of idea of like this is not
perfect but for what it gives it gives
really good and so I've definitely
saying Rotten Tomatoes is wrong okay I
first of all if there's a member of the
fresh ketchup Crew That's like listen to
every show can you compile a list has
Jacqueline referenced Constantine more
than I've referenced Van Halen I want to
see who is leading that race with her
definitely beat you over that because it
is still the movie basically I'm like is
it good is it better or worse than
Constantine but that's why it's exciting
to do this podcast because occasionally
we do feel like not necessarily
influence policy but people hear the
show and they say maybe I'll revisit
this Sister Act 2 was like 17 when we
talked about it it's it's gone up yeah
um the concept it was that low yeah
right that was a big deal it's a great
moment I think it's up to his 30s now
yeah which is amazing and I do think
that is the podcast effect a quick quick
question another movie that comes to
mind which for me is sort of in a
similar category to the cell that I
don't think it was necessarily well
received was Prometheus I loved Premiere
okay that is another one but that one
like Guy Ritchie being painted as an old
person just cast an old person but
that's neither
that one had fresh reviews though
Prometheus was the opposite audiences
hate it but critics liked it for the
most part I don't like uh Prometheus
look beautiful I don't like when
astronauts have sex in space
um keep it in your face until you get
back on Earth you don't know what's out
there you don't know what's going from
one body to the other one so we're here
to talk about the cell we also want to
give a shout out to some of our
editorials that are on
rottentomatoes.com right now including
all the Jennifer Lopez movies ranked is
Selena number one if not it should be
we'll probably talk about our favorite
Jayla movie by the end of this uh the 14
rotten horror movies we love is one of
the editorial movies and I believe the
cell is amongst those but like we said
it's horror-ish but there's also a lot
of other genres this movie covers most
of the bases at Blockbuster video and
the cell is featured in the book Rotten
Tomatoes rotten movies we love by Rotten
Tomatoes so Jacqueline I now turn it
over to you you have the tree of giving
us the synopsis of what exactly the cell
is about so the sell Stars Jennifer
Lopez and Vincent nofrio she plays a
criminal criminologist and psychiatrist
and Vince Vaughn sorry as well and also
Vince Vaughn that is the other thing
about this movie is the two the dueling
Vince's and Vince Vaughn um and she is
basically enlisted by the Federal Bureau
of Investigation because Vincent
d'onofio's character is in a coma and
they do not know where his last victim
is he puts all of his victims in these
elaborate cases which basically slowly
drown them over time and he's been there
in a race against the clock to find out
where his last victim is before he
either dies or they're really trying to
figure this out and they're using a new
technology which allows Catherine the
criminal psychologist to go inside of
his Consciousness to delve into the deep
recesses of his mind to hopefully find
Clues as to where this girl could be
hidden while he's existing in the coma
the interesting part is is while you're
living in this thriller cop genre the
minute you step inside the serial
Killer's head you were transported into
what could basically be described as
Guillermo del corturo's best fantasy and
ladies and gentlemen that is how you get
locked into the cell yeah it gets a
little wacky it did make me wonder what
what like if y'all went inside my brain
What would like it would probably just
be that green chair I have that doesn't
go with anything else in my house and uh
football some snacks some football a dog
that's really all but you go inside the
mind of a serial killer
gets a little loony yeah is all we're
gonna say so we think right we all think
Rotten Tomatoes got this one a little
wrong I can get it to fresh as well I I
also think the Rotten Tomatoes is wrong
I think that this uh deserves to be a
fresh movie but that's what we think
we're gonna get in the movie talking
just a little bit but first our good
buddy Tim Ryan the expert review
curation manager here at Rotten Tomatoes
it's going to tell us what critics we're
saying at the time when Daniella was in
eighth grade with the critics were
saying about the
cell's saying cut his teeth on music
videos directing striking clips for En
Vogue Suzanne Vega and most notably REM
in a 2016 interview with rolling stone
about the making of the video for Losing
My Religion tarsum said he was inspired
by Bollywood the paintings of Caravaggio
and a short story by Gabrielle Garcia
Marquez it was a heady mix which cleaned
up at the 1991 MTV Video Music Awards
beating out clips from such heady
hitters as herb Ritz Julian Temple
Michael Bay and David Fincher so no one
could deny that Tarzan Singh had a
unique artistic sensibility but when it
came to his first feature the cell
critics felt the visuals were undeniably
dazzling and haunting but were in the
service of a slim plot and thinly
sketched characters the cell is rotten
at 45 on the Tomato Meter with 164
reviews and it has a 57 audience score
so what did the critics have to say in a
rotten review Lou luminic of the New
York Post wrote If Looks Could Kill this
would be the best movie of the summer
but beneath the considerable eye candy
the cell is an awfully generic variation
on the overworked serial killer genre
however in a fresh review Peter Travers
of Rolling Stone wrote Tarson uses the
dramatically shallow plot to create a
dream world densely packed with images
of beauty and Terror that cling to the
memory even if you don't want them to
the Rotten Tomatoes critics consensus
reads the cell offers disturbing
stunning eye candy but its visual
Pleasures are no match for a confused
storyline that undermines the movie's
inventive aesthetic so that's the cell
and I know I only mentioned this earlier
but tarson's video for Hold On by En
Vogue is Hypnotic you should check it
out if you haven't seen it back to you
folks thank you Tim for letting us know
what was going on in the year 2000. it
was remember that Conan bit it was um
Andy Richter with a flashlight so we're
gonna get into movie talk about the cell
a movie that reminds a lot of people's
science of the Lambs and also I'm gonna
put Nightmare Elm Street in there cue
movie talk
oh
before we get into the comparisons with
this is as good as Silence of the Lambs
or where does this fit in Freddy
Krueger's world let's just talk about
Jennifer Lopez the light the Luminous
being known as Jennifer Lopez who has
blessed us here on Earth with her
presence uh why do we love JLo so much
what is her best movie
is it shotgun wedding I think JLo has an
every woman appeal as when she wants to
but it is like in every woman that you
know is not every woman it's very hard
to be that every woman you know what I
mean like she is the type of every woman
that a lot of women would aspire to be
but can achieve in the best way possible
whereas in Reese Witherspoon is the
opposite she's an every woman who is
exactly who these women are and so they
identify with her in a completely
different way and she's the Tom Brady of
Latinos yeah
um she just keeps going the extra mile
her numbers don't decrease they only
increase she's like an automaton I don't
know how she does it but also I think
challenges the notion that like you know
after 35 ladies are disposable and she's
like yeah I'm gonna return that on its
head that's stupid I do appreciate she's
a woman that knows her brand and her
brand is bigger than anybody ever wanted
it to be I do think this movie is her
most off-brand film but I do think it's
her coolest movie that might be why it's
got such a cool kick to it because it's
Jennifer Lopez doing this like I first
came across JLo when the Smash Hit
Anaconda hit theater and I love me a
good snake movie I'm terrified of snakes
I'm like Indiana Jones I am terrified of
snakes in real life I love him to death
I'm fascinated horrified by him and the
cool thing about Anaconda I was doing
some research on this Jennifer Lopez was
one of the first to say no I deserve
equal pay you're gonna pay Ice Cube or
whoever else this and I think she made
the point like to her agent and to the
exact like hey who do you think is
bringing in all of these females to come
see this movie yeah
do you think it's John Boyd doing a
crazy accent yeah it's me you know what
movie it was that she made that happen
onto it was the wedding planner with
Matthew McConaughey because he was a
bankable uh leading man sure and the
other kicker with that one is the same
weekend she was number one at the box
office she also had the number one
single I remember that that was like one
of the first times an artist had the
number one movie at the box office and
the number one single on the radio you
better pay her if not more if not more
yeah yeah I also declare the same thing
I want equal pay exactly I mean like
again you're all showing up for the same
horrible conditions but this is the
thing it still doesn't exist because
look what happened to
um Mark Wahlberg and Michelle Williams
the same days oh yeah on a reshoot to
save the film from Kevin Spacey he got
paid she didn't oh it happens like that
yeah that Ridley Scott movie I got and
this is the kicker about that whole
thing
she had the same agents
it's not all of them were good some of
them are snakes just like the ones
you are amazing yeah they're here in the
room hi agents
um if we look at Jennifer Lopez in the
context of the cell and so like she was
just starting to get hot like Selena had
come out and and Selena was a revelation
if Selena came out today that's an Oscar
nomination for sure that movie comes out
Anaconda is a big hit so she started to
get some steam in terms of being a a
film-going presence an A-list actress
when the cell comes out I remember
seeing ads for it and knowing who Vince
Vaughn was and knowing who Jennifer
Lopez was and kind of getting into these
trippy things I don't think I ever saw
this in a theater did you see it in the
theater were you like oh I need to see
this opening weekend oh yeah yeah in
fact I remember uh theater was packed
and I remember where I was sitting I I
remember it pretty I remember it pretty
vividly yeah I was from Northern
California yeah I'm from Oakland yeah
and I also remember that I was in love
with Vince Vaughn because I had also
seen swingers and I thought swingers was
the coolest movie ever so for me it had
my crush and it had like my little hero
so for me it was a big deal how about
Jaclyn Coley
Austin I remembered that Vincent
D'Onofrio was creepy from Full Metal
Jacket I did not think that that was
going to change this film I was right
I was an HBO watch first for me because
I do very remember the cell like the you
know HBO used to have the like images
come down and then it would like show
Jennifer Lewis in that moment so I think
this was a HBO movie for me I think this
was a Netflix sending me the DVD and and
popping it in and then popping it back
in the mail but I I re-washed it again
and I thought I was going to blow
y'all's Minds with how smart I am with
what an amazing film Watcher I've become
because as soon as this movie came on I
remembered very little about it so I put
this on a couple nights ago me and Molly
the Wonder Dog were sitting there we're
watching the cell and within two seconds
I'm thinking this feels like a movie
that I loved that I think came out in
2008 called The Fall directed by tarsome
Singh and I'm like I'm gonna impress
them with my knowledge it comes directed
by Tarzan saying oh my God damn it this
guy's they're gonna know so but it did
feel like the fall before the fall yeah
just visually yeah and it's like that
guy has such a signature style yeah he
sort of got like like I think
corporatized by the producers with the
Immortals it doesn't say he did the
immortal which unfortunately the worst
part about that was is everyone called
him a Zack Snyder ripoff
that's the biggest disservice to him
because honestly I think it was partly
Zack Snyder didn't like that and that
was also what was like this is the thing
that happens sometimes when people get
labeled the Ripoff of somebody else yeah
if that person doesn't like that they
maybe make that comparison and not the
best ways right I'll gladly they'll be
the best JLo rip-off I'll take that I I
want that for you I really do and I see
that for you I want to be the Kirkland
JLo I mean
that's the dream because you know how
many guys at the gym want to be knock
off Gerard Butler they want to be the Dr
perky to his Dr Pepper I mean I don't
want to say which guys you're probably
looking at one of them
yeah but you're doing so well being the
knockoff toe for Grace well the thing
about Vince Vaughn too I'm definitely a
second right if you go to the Topher
gray store and you can't afford Topher
Grace
if you want Suburban Eminem you come to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong anyway I feel
bad for that you're not the discount
anyone you are the First Rate Mark Ellis
yeah well thank you
okay well back to this movie that we all
agree it should be fresh I wonder why is
the movie Rotten I I maybe I don't know
what critics were thinking at the time
but when you saw it and when you see it
now when you re-watch it what is it
about this movie that leaps out to you
and it's like no this is this is a cool
fresh movie yeah well at the time it
felt really fresh because uh well I love
horror and I love when it feels like
this is a movie that the uh director uh
darson saying that he wouldn't make and
I love when people who probably would
have nothing to do with the genre do
their take on a genre and this was so
many layers it was like sci-fi and it
was beautiful and it was scary there was
also humor in it
um it just it Corp it weaved together a
lot of different things that felt very
new to me
um and very Grand and even though it was
like in someone's brain it always felt
like a wide shot and it always felt big
yeah and it to me the technology was
really exciting because I think one when
we're kids we're always like hey hey
we're friends what if we could have like
the same dream and like kind of like
hang out in that world and now you kind
of get to do that you get to crawl into
somebody else's head which is why I
reference Nightmare on Elm Street yes
but the only you know I guess the
criticism I was a lot of this movie is
that I felt like we sort of took a
biopsy of what it's like to be in
somebody's head and we didn't really get
the full spectrum of it we just got a
little sliver and I wanted more because
there's all this like just amazing
visual artistic Vision that you see when
you get inside a Serial Killer's head
when you get inside Jennifer Lopez's
head doesn't matter but I wanted more
even more disturbing and less beautiful
yeah there's a lot of beauty and it
could have been a little more rotten and
mean it is there I think we're Jaded by
that but like there's so many images in
that that are literally like genuinely I
think like jaw-droppingly disturbing
everything from like hanging his skin oh
yeah that like I literally when I was
watching this I forgot how much of that
like 2000s R-rated horror that we were
allowed to receive at that time we are
not allowed to receive now that is yeah
Missing You could argue that the the
real world is scarier than the sort of
dream inside your own head world that
you get in this movie because there
there's two sort of Landscapes you get
you get what's happening with looking
for this crime where this guy played by
uh you know Vincent D'Onofrio who was
even more weirder than he was in like
the as the Extraterrestrial in Men In
Black or as Kingpin he's like hanging
himself by his back
ah that looked painful yeah when he he
puts these hooks into his back and into
his calves and then he just suspends
himself and it just looked like man
looking at Nine Inch Nails music video
yeah it was like kind of like a little
metal yeah don't you just want to do a
puzzle no it isn't there yes
hobby that you could pick but it's it's
the battle of the serial killers because
Vince Vaughn was a pretty good Weirdo
And psycho a couple years before the
remix
it was a pretty hot suit at the time
you're checking into that basement I
would have been a victim what's
interesting with this one I'm showering
I don't know if anybody oh no babes tell
your son
um the other thing that I I will say is
one of my favorite genres of like
psychological horror is is something
that is somewhat metaphysical or kind of
straddling Dimensions or you know where
you're kind of weaving in reality and
this movie really did that for me I
really loved that and it's it's not it's
not easy to pull off no especially when
it's a Race Against Time yes which is
what we we have to find this new victim
that Carl the serial killer has encased
in glass and is about to drown and so
that's where this movie really ramped up
for me like I was intrigued by the
technology of it I like the stars and so
automatically I'm in it's a cool
landscape but then the fact that it
feels almost like an episode of 24 where
it's like we gotta get to the end of
this and there's like a finite amount of
time once the water starts I mean it
sort of felt like a precursor to saw in
a way
you know I was thinking I was thinking
about what you were saying though as you
were saying it and I was like I really
Wonder though how much of this was JLo
backlash
as you were saying that I'm listening to
you and like we're all thinking about
like why why why with all these movies
sometimes there's always something
that's that's there that we can't really
hear like like scoring underneath it and
I do think that it needs to be
appreciated with especially women of
color but especially JLo and how she
went about it this is not too long after
the Cameron Diaz quotes and such there
was a bit of a JLo backlash because she
became such of a phenomenon and I think
this was the beginning of that this was
the beginning of people being like so
she thinks very highly of herself you
know what I mean do you remember that
yeah right around that time and she's
and she's touched on it yeah yeah yeah
she's brought that up that that is a
possibility I should be very clear this
was uh Jennifer Lopez had a very you
know I would say tell all interview
where she's pretty candid with a
journalist where she talked about
basically who she thought uh had talent
in Hollywood and who didn't and then
there there's a famous quote that said
Cameron Diaz was a lucky model yeah
I gotta tell you at least I'm really
thankful that no one put a mic in my
face my second third year in this
business there's a being a public person
is a learning experience and she is far
more uh far more experienced than that
than than I do and you um you're young
and you're cocky and you're full of
energy and you're just calling it like
you see it and then you get older and
you're like people often regret it I've
been guilty of it yeah so I'm glad we
have editors for this year I mean it's
yeah every day thank you Brian
appreciate you for making me not near as
dumb as this once a month I have to call
Brian I'm like hey that one thing yeah
the thing that wakes you up at night
you're like I don't know if I should say
that actually one of the people I
actually like um and I am okay with
standing in publicly is Bill Hader
because one of my favorite quotes of his
is like yeah oh you're a bill hater fan
yeah Hey listen this is why though he
says the reason why I'm not on the
Internet is because I am often wrong and
I do not need a place that can get from
my wrong thoughts to Pub public and what
I would just say about Jennifer Lopez is
unfortunately with very famous people
that is not the case but even more
importantly I think with her I'm sure
she definitely obviously regrets like
her honesty and everything at that time
but in a lot of ways look at how
ambitious she was and then maybe looking
at a lot of people who maybe received
her same level without any level of
ambition like this is literally a girl
from the Bronx that was like a woman and
you're a woman and you're a woman of
color and I think a lot of people and
Meghan Markle is a clear example of this
there is an idea of once you ascend to a
certain level it puts people out of
joint just by you existing at that
certain level and people also want to
keep you in the box that they discovered
you in and and for her I think that you
can so like I'm watching this movie
right and I see it's 45 of the Tomato
Meter so I'm just trying to equate like
this movie how does it get that score
and I think one of the through lines is
people saw JLo as a music artist first
and foremost and it's you can you can
look at this movie and look at the
visuals that starts from sing puts in
and you say oh this is just a glorified
music video which it's not but on the
surface you can see like these elaborate
costumes and these crazy set designs and
like what the hell is going on it does
feel like it would have been a really
cool music video but there's so much
more substance to that and that's what I
think maybe folks missed at the time in
2000 when this came out yeah and also
mind you know I'm a big fan and and I
know them the everything everywhere all
at once those were a sequence of music
video ideas that then got woven into
something so sometimes music video
vignette it hits watch a movie without
music yeah and let me know how it goes
yeah also this too this is also um a
perfect example of how cyclical uh
critical reception is and how critical
reception is never about Innovation is
always about expectation critics are
happy when they when you give them what
they expect and you do it well they are
not often happy when you do something
unexpected that they didn't enjoy even
if you do it well and this is an example
of that they were expecting because this
is the other thing about the cell when
you go into the movie you kind of expect
to be one way and it sort of divides the
two and so it looks more like this very
high art fantasy film and when you start
it you're in the middle of basically a
Law and Order episode yeah that
expectation is a bit of I would say a
disconnect and I think for this one in
particular that disconnect was probably
what got critics a bit out of Joy like
and and there was a backlash to stylized
Cinema because at that time people like
Roger Ebert and a lot of these really
established film critics did not think
that anybody from that genre was going
to be able to make it as a film director
this before Fincher did his thing this
is back when like Hype Williams and
folks like that would do one movie and
it would fail I think Ebert was the was
the outlier for liking this yes
a lot of other critics a lot of other
critics but establishment we're saying
thumbs down they were like this is a
music video and back at that time that
was enough for people to hate it that's
so silly it's ridiculous when you look
at it especially again when you have
like the fact that there are boats on
the ground we gotta we gotta save this
we got to save this girl in time
favorite scenes in this movie where do
we go did we do you go maybe towards the
like inside the mind or do you go like
pursuing the the Eve I'll tell you what
I love in this movie is I first of all
the the technological aspect like I said
is fascinating I love just the look of
the design of the suits and it's very
evident in a cool way that tarsum Singh
saw Bram Stoker's Dracula and the
designer for that is Aiko ishioka and
he's like I want that person to do this
and you can kind of see a lot of
similarities from Bram Stoker's Dracula
the suit that Gary Oldman wears in the
beginning what like that that is all
like like like burgundy with like the
muscle kind of night thing yeah that's
what they're wearing to like get into
this and then once you get in there you
see a lot of like the costumes and
similarities I love when Vince Vaughn's
character Peter is like I plugged me in
I'm going in you got a third Bay I'm
going in part of my brain likes it
because I like being the hero like just
put me in there let's go this yeah but
the other part of me loves that he gets
his comeuppance as immediately as he
gets in there and he starts getting his
intestines ripped out he's like what the
hell is happening in here I think as
soon as he's in there correct me if I'm
wrong as soon as he's in there it's the
three people who are like yeah I mean
and he's like oh I'm out of my depth why
did I do this do you have a favorite do
you have a favorite moment from it
um you know funny enough there's so many
good moments like the horse being sort
of extended out and cut with glass and
you can kind of see it pull something
yeah I thought that was pretty metal but
you know actually the thing that I
always remember as as a kid
was when she's kind of walking and
looking around and there's like a
bodybuilder woman that's like walking
toward her like I was like make that
horror movie yeah I love the picture of
the horse I again there's so many
moments in this movie you guys love
turning this poor horse into glue it was
cool it's just a very stylized and cool
shot and the thing I love about this
movie in the sense of like no horses
were harmed right that's true it's a
digital shot
um sure it looked real to me that's the
point that means they did a good job
it's this thing called the movies I have
a nightmare
um but the thing I will say about it is
I think this is a love letter to style
over substance in the best way possible
and the reason why people didn't dig it
is because of its female protagonist
because 300 is all Style no substance
you know what I mean there's so many
male generated movies that are all Style
no substance all action no you know meat
to it yeah this one actually had both
yeah and and still the style was just so
resting and I feel like again it was a
backlash of that but this film walked so
that the throne room scene in Black
Panther could run so that Sam Ramey's
um Doctor Strange can have its moment
like all of these very stylized action
movies that we've seen in later years
this is sort of I think the Bedrock
movie to really show again like you can
go there it's a bit of a rothko right
it's a bit of laying the foundations and
pretty ahead of its time and people
looked at it and they were like what is
that yeah and now it's like no in order
to have this you had to have that
absolutely like apparently a lot of the
reason why this movie got the green line
in the first place was because of 90s
horror films where you had Silence of
the Lambs which feels similar but then
you also had the Sixth Sense which came
out the year before which is just a
monster hit you also had the Matrix and
the Matrix was very stylized and you had
the bullet time and you had the
elaborate costuming external leading
towards this it was leading towards this
but it was still in the real world it
was still real bullets and granted it
was like stylized added to the suit
blend it was a flavor that you added to
it yeah you get the cool this that and
the other but it's still guys dodging
bullets this was literally like
yeah you couldn't tell these were
characters this literally
ugly Matrix wasn't the real world it's
fair you know what I mean yeah real
world I think y'all took different pills
yeah exactly
exactly real world elements in the sense
that like they're trying to exist within
the framework or whatever the other
thing with the cell is you're trapped in
imagination that is literally what
you're trapped in you're trapped in
imagination which is Limitless yeah
which that's what makes it more scary
but that's also what makes it I think
harder for audiences to sort of like
latch into it yeah if you are Jennifer
Lopez and you know we do spoilers on
this on this show so if you are like
luring a serial killer into your brain
as she does towards the end of this
movie she gives herself like a cool
crossbow but that's like what you're
relying on is your weapon of choice
seems a little risky to me I think that
again is another example of the style
because what you realize is she didn't
need the crossbow right because once he
was in her mind she was in control she
still the crossbow still came in handy
Mr Christmas still came in handy
obviously but I guess that's my whole
point is like the scariest moment in
that moment and I think what my favorite
moment in the movie is is in the end
where she was just like oh no no sweetie
I'm not trapped in here with you you're
trapped in here with me yep like that I
think that was the line from the trailer
in fact yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's a
good line yeah that was the one that was
you know that's the queen takes the Rook
that is like we are really living in our
power in this and that's obviously the
best outfit she's in in the entire thing
it's like everything sort of hits with
that and that to me yeah I think that's
what separates it from it is the
Simplicity of the idea that like she
takes control she didn't need anybody to
save her and because it is within her
mind
she can be a limitless savior not a
limitless villain yeah she was the hero
Vince Vaughn was just kind of there yeah
he needed rescue him yeah that's why I
love that scene that I met you because
he thought he was going to be the hero
yeah he was like yeah plug me in I'll
get this thing done in 15 minutes I got
a gun I got a badge what are they gonna
do I'm a man with all my manly things of
course I can fix this you just see and
the cool part about this is why I like
it like nightmare in Elm Street is where
sometimes you can have something happen
in your head and it and it's so visceral
and it's so it just like up in your face
it changes the chemistry and now you
think that's real life and so for the
rest of the movie Vince Vaughn's got a
pretty badass tummy ache yeah because he
got his intestine ripped out in somebody
else's head so now he's limping around
like he's got an ulcer I don't know what
what the end game of that is yeah yeah
but it seems to me like he's just gonna
be living with this tummy pain for the
rest of his life or at least give me a
while with a hernia I mean at least a
good while like if like like you know a
phantom pain or like hypnosis we're like
yeah for a while you're gonna feel this
dream for sure but it's gonna you're
eventually gonna shake it off good luck
dating that guy because he's waking up
in a cold sweat he's gonna be more like
Vince Vaughn in the breakup oh yeah
nice throwback that's why he's driving
that bus oh by the way uh this movie
does end on sort of a there's a couple
open-ended things that I like one of
them is that the the movie at the outset
Jennifer Lopez a psychologist character
is trying to get through to this kid
who's been in a coma yeah and so now
that they've proven with their backs
against the wall that you don't have to
go into their head you can make them go
into your head and maybe that's the way
you heal this boy I think that's all
going to work out just fine that's my
prediction for the movie
but I'm also wondering is that really
safe or does it go horribly horribly
wrong I mean that's the other kicker on
that too you can't bring a crossbow to
the poor little kid I mean more
importantly the kid the kid taking over
is more what I say it's like once he
starts fiddling around with her head
looking for revenge like again like he
looks like a little cute boy well you
know so did Carl the serial killer
exactly I I think you're right I think
maybe it doesn't work out and it should
be a cautionary tale because Elon Musk
was trying to get in all our heads and I
don't think that's gonna end up too well
so anything starting with those two
names I don't think is going to be
ending yeah however he is producing the
next Tom Cruise Space movie
um so uh Elon Hi how are you if you need
a female on that spaceship you let me
know available
what's it like to wear a flight
attendant suit
for
a couple months you asked that it was
the same one they never look comfortable
and I always feel bad for the flight
attendants because like can't you get
some I mean you're on a flight when I'm
on a flight I'm wearing I'm this isn't
the 40s I'm not going in a suit and a
hat yeah I'm sweats I'm basically in my
pajamas yeah this skirt was uh you know
it's it's a it's a slim skirt it's like
a what do you call that like a like a
skinny skirt so it you know it's it's
kind of constricting a little cumbersome
yeah yeah just a bit you being a flight
attendant is not in your backup plan
anymore
um I have a newfound respect for flight
attendants like a hundred percent
because it's a was it yesterday
I mean at one point anything could have
been in my backup plan uh but uh no uh I
I uh I have a newfound respect for it
because you got to be in that pencil
skirts pencil skirt and then you you
know you're serving drinks and you're
risking your life just to give these
people some peanuts and drinks you know
and their safety irresponsible for their
safety I definitely so my uncle's a
pilot and the only thing I ever envied
about flight attendant was the
free-flying thing because I'm just like
Escape was the first thing I understood
as a child we must leave
um but now no like now no like
High-Speed Rail cannot come quick enough
because all the crappy aspects of flight
are still there in like rail travel yeah
but you just care way less because
you're on the ground oh yeah yeah big
time um I will say in comparison to uh
the cell it's probably a much more
manageable outfit to wear whereas like
in the cell I imagine Vincent
d'onofrio's in that like puffy giant
like Dracula thing and then he's like
sitting in his chair and it's like all
uncomfortable in revery yeah that seems
so I love the pictures of the set where
it's like somebody in a like elaborate
costume and they're taking a break and
they're just like smoking it oh yeah
it's like covered in a color and they're
just like smoke yeah
I love that stuff he has no lines but I
swear to you he earned and he earned an
Oscar for what he had to go through he's
like no like it has a couple but he has
so few lines in this and the fact that
like yeah what he had to go through in
like a couple of little quotes yeah yeah
and then he has a couple quotes when
he's regular he's like out and about
before they discover him he talked to
somebody random like you know that kind
of stuff but again
the costumes just like his the big one
from the book because this film is also
featured in the book where he's wearing
is basically his version of Tim Curry's
Darkness from Legend yeah you know like
all of that is hours of context and this
was back when that stuff was not coming
oh so annoying people have no idea this
was the same year that uh Jim Carrey's
uh How the Grinch Stole Christmas came
out yeah and his contact lenses were the
toughest part of like that Grinch makeup
yeah you know a lot of it's just his
face yeah five hours to get on five
hours to get off the contact lenses were
the thing that pushed him over the edge
same thing with actually Robert
who made them do it
did just good for him yeah I fully I
support that you ain't messing with my
eyes you can microchip my brain but you
ain't messing with my eyes yeah I'm
gonna uh sign out on both I think that
before if you're one of these people and
you want to be microchipped fine but you
should have to watch the cell first just
because there's but like the cell might
be the best at least recently of any of
these psychological horror movies where
you actually go inside somebody's head
because it can get really bad really
fast like the the movie Transcendence
yeah a lot of the sequels nightmare in
Elm Street it's like what are we even
doing here but this one like so I I did
want to get deeper and I like that
that's my complaint as a moviegoer is
that I wanted to get deeper into what
was going on because it felt like I
don't know it felt a little like Tron
legacy to me where we're just kind of
making up the rules as we go yeah the
thing that bugged me about Tron legacy
is like this kid has never played the
sport before and he instantly becomes
LeBron James yeah and with this it's
like well I want to know why how do you
get powers in this world how do you how
do you take power away from somebody
else it's more than just now you're in
my head and I can make the rules I just
want to see how that kind of works but
maybe maybe that could have been for the
sequel I also feel like uh you know
maybe in the screenwriters again uh
kudos to them I do think that they
did the job
um but I will say it would have been
pretty cool if you did have like a super
like crime True Crime like serial killer
profiling nerd to kind of add a little
flourishes in there to make it more you
know like if if we're gonna make a movie
about getting into Richard Ramirez's
head that's the scariest movie yeah it's
not gonna be beautiful it's gonna be
it's going to be hell it's gonna be a
nightmare it's gonna make Freddy Krueger
look like Disneyland
like Disneyland is exactly yeah the
casting of the other scientists I
thought was great um I love the these
sort of like a character actor Dylan
Baker because he's the ultimate like
nerdy white guy who gets the line in
every like big budget alien movie where
he's like taking off his glasses and
he's like the ship's already arrived
like that kind of thing he's got the
that permanent frightened white guy
neighbor face
yeah is there a line in this where it's
like we're inside yeah
we're inside yeah no there's definitely
that you gotta have that one oh
version of this character is Jason
Isaacs and Armageddon he's the one well
if you want to listen to the man who
failed his MIT physics class for your
jet propulsions you can and then he
leaves the movie and never shows up
again I don't know what happened to
Jason Isaacs on that movie but he came
in he was a smart ass for one scene and
then left I'm pretty sure the only
reason Paul Giamatti signed on to be in
San Andreas was so he could deliver
those lines
sideways is my favorite movie of all
time sorry oh wait a minute number one I
don't know why I didn't say this don't
you play the smartest person in the room
in Jurassic world basically kind of like
you do that I do I yes that is correct
wait a minute we're sitting with the
version I know and yet we're listening
to not the all the you know the gutsiest
the brave people the smart person never
is the one who's like you were literally
like screaming we need to do this yeah I
love it too there is something I do in
that movie that has always bugged me and
it pisses me off every time I see it I'm
like why did I do that that's so stupid
there's a moment where um is this Fallen
Kingdom or Dominion this is Fallen
Kingdom Chris and Bryce they're
characters they ask me something we're
like we're together and we're inside
this uh the back of this truck and under
like an awning and and the Raptors on
the table and my hand is covered in dry
blood and I'm literally going
oh
doctor whatever and I know
if we're watching that like stupid
movies yeah it's my biggest regret yeah
but you're so accustomed to being just
soaked in blood I mean there's dinosaur
chaos going on all over the place no no
she's a good actor it's like no I'm
putting some I'm putting some intensity
to this I'm getting some movement in
this scene I'm not gonna be standing I'm
gonna try and add a little bit more in
this very big action movie without
remembering the fact that you have like
fake pain no it's maybe the dumbest
thing in the entire movie it's not the
dumbest thing in the entire movie your
lead actress ran in heels I'm so sorry
like that was the first one but still if
there's dumb moments in this franchise I
have to point out to you that she was
wearing the heels because that's what
the male
character was and she was playing the
role and she didn't know she was gonna
get chased by dinosaurs
defense I gotta come to Bryce's defense
on this uh no one ever looks at Beyonce
like how do you do a tour in heels she
does that entire tour yeah it can be
done
I think that subject needs to be put to
rest that doesn't need to be put arrest
but basically what I'm saying no one is
laughing at you like there's been plenty
of things the internet to be mad about I
don't think your hand was one of them
although I do appreciate the like self
and Analysis to be like I know somebody
is pissed off about this and my trauma
will make me feel that it's more than
that but I know somebody is pissed off
about this I think the last few years
have all taught us to wash our hands
more I will still take the dog walk I'll
pick up her stuff and then I'll go right
back in the house and drink a beer and
not think about it and not think about
how close the hands are like eat the
chicken nuggets just just live with
someone they remind you yeah because I
like don't want to do that I don't take
care of my body like at all anything
that is involved with this shell like
I'm just pretending that it exists
without sustenance food or any kind of
like taking care of like I clean my body
but like just the idea of like cleaning
Your Vessel I clean my vessel but I just
don't take care of it I'm not
celebrating yeah so it's nice when
somebody like he doesn't even like me to
bring the poop up he's like you should
just throw it away downstairs why are we
still throwing away the poop that's what
the neighbor's trash can is for I agree
with that yeah yeah yeah yeah we're
gonna transition from wiping fake blood
on your face and dog food
unceremoniously and cleaning up poop two
your favorite J1 movie of all time we
started with it we're gonna end with it
if you have one movie to take with you
on the ship to go to the next planet and
it's a J-Lo movie which flick are we
taking her new movie shotgun wedding
it's on Amazon where dog stepfather
lives the wonderful stand-up special
where I do talk about cleaning up
Molly's poop is it a rom-com or is it
like something like Selena which is
music and tragedy is this yeah you know
is it Anaconda oh God this is a this is
a tough one I will say her top movie on
the Tomato Meter is a top Contender of
mine and that's not that's 94 out of
sight yeah oh right that bathtub scene
still holds up yeah maybe you know what
actually I'll tell you which one I'm
taking okay
um I would say Selena but it's too
depressing and I always get really
really sad when I watch it even though
there's a speech in that with Edward
James almost and um they're in the car
and they're talking about what it's like
be Mexican if you're from Mexico and you
make fun of Mexican Americans you need
to watch that scene and if you're white
and you tell someone they're not really
Mexican you need to watch that scene I
wish that that scene would just play 24
7. is this one of those movies that you
want to cut off like 10 minutes before
it ends it's so depressing no but I'm
taking jiggly
oh wow I'm taking jiggly you're taking
chili yeah yeah the Gili I'm taking the
jealous may I ask why you know what
because sometimes you just gotta watch
an incredible Calamity sometimes you
just want to watch who you're you you
there's two people in love and I support
love man I love that you're going to
this new planet based on my premise and
the way that you're introducing this new
race of people to cinema
actress Daniella Pineda brought one
movie and it's Julie arguably the most
critically hated movie of the last 30
years yeah and did Martin breast's
career
oh did it the great director of Beverly
Hills Cop I will say Jersey girl yeah
which also was was Ben Affleck and
Jennifer Lopez but she that's not a JLo
movie though it's it's a Kevin Smith
movie but it's it's better than other
than Haley I imagine okay what are you
taking and can it compete with Julie
well that's what she's about to say I
had to go look at her filmography
because I can
I wanted to feel like
for example for me I wouldn't a Jersey
girl in there and I wouldn't put out of
sight even in there because as much of
those are movies that star her they're
not her movies like you know what I mean
and I do feel to your point it does need
to be a rom-com and so that was down to
two for me and that was Monster-in-Law
or made in Manhattan because those are
my two favorites I think her favorites
made in Manhattan I think hers is made
in Manhattan too and I would go with
that one just because of all the leading
men that she had the only one that I
would think about is Rafe that's true
he's the classiest of all of them what
are you talking about like a wedding
planner McConaughey he's right there
it's not what I want to date I'm sure
he's great I don't want to date him I
want to date Ray fine so now I would
still also date refunds like in the in
the menu refunds any any time of day
year or month I mean Voldemort over
Matthew McConaughey even in the makeup
girl he's smart he's smart he's smart
you know what it is it doesn't matter
what he looks like he can stimulate your
mind and that has one of the greatest
JLo lines where she says she walks in in
her Cinderella moment it has a
Cinderella moment it's of the two movies
that have like this Cinderella moment
this is the best one but the best part
about it is she walks in and she's like
I just need you to know this can't go
past this evening and he's like well you
should have worn a different dress
you know
you know this is right I think the
casting on that should have switched
because Ray finds this too refined to be
a politician especially nowadays I think
and McConaughey was gonna apparently run
yeah I think he put Ray fines in the
wedding the wedding planner and you put
Matthew McConaughey in the maidenman it
would have live enough that made
Manhattan a little bit
a little dreary I know it's a I know
it's a romantic movie The Comedy a
little skimpy on the comedy for me I'm
taking the wedding planner I'm taking
McConaughey but you heard it first here
Mars the movies you're getting are Julie
and made in Manhattan thanks to Daniela
and Jacqueline no Anaconda no oh that
point that I was gonna say though
Anaconda when uh what's it Jon Voight is
Jon Voight where he spits him out and
then he goes
everything that this the cell gave us on
visual effects akanda took it took it
away yeah yeah that's true all right
well we gotta say goodbye to movie talk
for now that's the cell I think we all
agree that we proved Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong about that and then we maybe sell
it our own opinions in the process but
that's movie talk let's head over to
mailbag
[Music]
this week we have ketchup crew member
Ryan painter one of our favorites who
says how have you not done the prophecy
from 1995 with Christopher Walken Eric
Stoltz and a pre-order of the Rings
Viggo Mortensen but post Young Guns Too
Viggo Mortensen walking is at his creepy
and campy best this movie has been
absolutely wrong then an historic wrong
must be righted Ryan painter oh I'll be
honest with you Ryan I believe I saw the
prophecy maybe classic video update was
my video store as a ute and uh
Williamsburg Virginia we didn't have
Blockbuster but we had video update and
I remember seeing the prophecy remember
seeing Chris walking and it was always
like my back up or my second backup
movie and for whatever reason during
around that time I had a pretty good run
of whatever my first choice was going to
be being available because you know
sometimes you go there and it's like oh
Bram Stoker's Dracula isn't it I guess
it's it's Sister Act 2 again yeah but
here I think the prophecy was my backup
and it never got called up it never
actually got in the game you all see the
prophecy I have not years ago it's a
horror movie right yeah oh that was a
blockbuster horror section that's where
you could find me well I'll take your
prophecy and raise you a covenant
because that's the movie I always think
is the prophecy when I think of it but
the Covenant is the one that stars
Sebastian Stan and it's like skulls but
campy I love him all right well we are
unfortunately gonna have to say goodbye
to this episode we know we could talk
about this movie the cell and J1 movies
in Vince mon movies forever but it's
time to say goodbye to miss Daniela
Pineda but not before we get a
recommendation something streaming maybe
something you seem very excited about
what your recommendation was going to be
yes I am well um I've
about this before but my favorite
animation of all time that I grew up on
is beefs and butt head yes and Mike
Judge has just come out with his newest
season of Beavis and Butthead which is
streaming on Paramount plus and it is
awesome and they do he does a split I
think it's like every other episode they
do Beavis and Butthead now what they're
like oh yeah and it's incredible do they
do they still do music videos at all now
they just watch like YouTube videos yeah
so we
it's amazing um I actually got Beavis
and uh shout out to Paramount plus they
they keep me somewhat employed on the
moderator circuit so I love them um
actually it's funny we talked about made
in Manhattan the guy that played Teen
Wolf stars as Jennifer Lopez son in made
in Manhattan yes and it's uh the only
thing I was gonna add to all the
Martians I'm sure they'll be pleased you
brought that movie I mean maybe uh the
only thing I will add with the Beavis
and butt head of it is I uh absolutely
loved their latest effort it was it had
no reason to be this good and I just
feel like not that many people know
about it so I'm so glad you mentioned it
yeah it's so good like it's better in a
lot of ways I mean Beavis and Butthead
Do America the movie from the 90s is
fresh I believe in the Tomato Meter and
that was the first hint that we got of
who their parents were when they run
into like their maybe their future
selves it was like there were Roadies at
a Motley Crue concert I didn't know and
this totally blew my mind that um I I
didn't oh this is my favorite cartoon I
didn't know till recently that Mike
Judge is the one who does all the voices
literally like when that happened it was
like algorithms and a door and it was
like what is reality how did I not know
that and this is the man that made
Silicon Valley like when you look at his
filmography you're like man you don't
care bunny King of the Hill another
underrated in my opinion yep same it's
the best damn it Bobby if you ever get
the chance to plug yourself into the
cell like situation going to somebody
else's head Mike Judge be pretty funny
to go into him Robin Williams is Jim
Carrey I feel like all of them have
great inner monologues I don't know
about I don't know if I want to go
character
who are you tread with comedian Fair
yeah very dark very cool that's true all
right but always a light in our life is
Miss Daniella Pinedo you can currently
see on the big screen in plain again
congratulations it's a fresh movie I
know you got a lot of exciting stuff
coming up um is there anything you want
to plug or where can all the kids out
there find you
um you know I'm on I'm on the Instagram
at not Danielle Pineda
um and uh that's pretty fun you know I'm
really good on the gram with the kids
I'm not on the talk uh maybe I'll regret
that my career
um and I've got the plane uh which is
out with Gerard Butler and it is kick
ass and a lot of fun and we can have
sequels for forever I would do that hey
they did Greenland they made another
Greenland after that was a success I
don't see why there might not be a plane
too yeah I agree and just because I know
that we're taping this a couple weeks in
advance but the Super Bowl is this
Sunday do you think Cincinnati Bengals
are they going to be competing in
Arizona is Joe burro Joe bro uh shout
out to Bingle Barrel you know if you
like Cincinnati you know the Bingo
Barrel's God Jamar Chase I love you
watch Daniel's stories if you want to
know what Bingo Barrel is okay yeah
that's for like the deep cut the real
fans I'm gonna have to check this out
there you go Barrel running through
Bill's Mafia that's gonna be this is
gonna be good it's gonna be a whole
thing yeah okay make sure y'all check
out rottentomatoes.com that's sort of
our Hub everything from TV movies
everything in between the world of
entertainment subscribe rate review
whatever you choose to listen to this on
do what that service asks you to do for
this podcast thank you again to Danielle
Pineda to Jacqueline Coley to Brian
Perez our wonderful Engineers here in
studio the whole gang here at Rotten
Tomatoes I am really Mark Ellison thanks
for tuning in and we will see you next
week
[Music]
thank you